the top two purposes of every for-profit
company is to offer as much value as
possible and bring home as much profit
as possible
some companies are particularly good at
providing value while others are
phenomenal at generating profits but
very few companies are able to strike a
balance that pleases everyone one
company that has managed to achieve this
however is visa
generally it's the retailer or seller
paying credit card and debit card fees
so most customers never bat an eye to
them using a card is much more
convenient than carrying cash and change
and as for sellers most of them view the
one to three percent processing fee as
an acceptable investment because
accepting cards brings in so much more
traffic i mean just imagine where online
sales would be if it wasn't for cards on
the other side of the coin visa is
pretty happy as well even though they
only make a small fee on each
transaction americans alone spent 6.7
trillion through credit and debit cards
in 2019 and 60 of that was through visa
aside from pulling in massive revenue
visa has zero cogs or cost of goods sold
which means that their gross profit
margin is literally 100
even after you account for operating
expenses and taxes visa is able to bring
in 51 of their revenue as net profit
so here's the story of the most
profitable company in the world
taking a look back the origin of visa
dates all the way back to 1956 to bank
of america
at the time credit cards were already
quite popular amongst middle class
americans but the system was by no means
centralized or streamlined generally
merchants issued their own cards that
could be used to make purchases at their
stores and be paid off at the end of the
month but the problem was that each card
was specific to the merchant so they had
to carry a card for every retailer they
shopped at and at the end of the month
they had to pay off several bills
ironically the situation is basically
the same today as people use different
cards for groceries travel and gas to
maximize on their points but
theoretically people can just get away
with one or two credit cards if they
wanted to in the 1950s however this was
not possible many smaller banks had
already tried to create an all-around
credit card but given their relatively
small customer bases these never picked
up steam so when joseph p williams the
product development leader at bank of
america suggested creating a credit card
executives weren't quite convinced they
feared that not enough americans would
adopt the system and that merchants
would fight back but after a bit of
convincing it joseph was able to get
approval for a soft launch in fresno
california the executives felt that
fresno was big enough to give the system
a shot but it was also small enough that
if things went bad the company wouldn't
lose too much money something else to
note is that bank of america had 45
market share in fresno so you could say
that they had the cards stacked in their
favor
anyway on september 18th 1958 bank of
america finally launched bank americart
by shipping 65 000 cards to fresno
residents
the launch in fresno actually went
pretty well and bank of america was
feeling comfortable in expanding their
program but then rumors started to roll
around that another major bank was going
to launch their own credit card in san
francisco san francisco was bank of
america's home market so they couldn't
just let some competitor beat them to
market bank of america doubled down on
bank americart and pumped up card
issuance through the roof by march of
1959 they had sent out cards in san
francisco and sacramento by june they
added los angeles and by october they
had issued over 2 million credit cards
in terms of popularity bank americart
was a massive success as 20 000
merchants were accepting the card in
terms of media and profitability though
bank americart was having a rough time
you see joseph had vastly underestimated
the number of people who would take
advantage of the service joseph
anticipated that only four percent of
accounts would become delinquent but the
actual number came in at 22 percent in
the meantime bank of mere cards were the
perfect tool for fraudsters leading to
the rise of credit card fraud now bank
of america had thought about this and
their terms of service specified that
customers would be liable for fraudulent
charges
but the media and politicians just ate
this up and destroyed the reputation of
bank americart by 1960 bank of america
had racked up 20 million losses and the
joseph would throw in the towel by
resigning bank of america however was
determined to make this work they had
seen how quickly merchants and customers
adopted the system and they knew that
they had something massive on their
hands bank of america simply sent out an
apology to their 3 million customers and
they simply stayed the course
by may of 1961 the venture would turn
profitable but bank of america didn't
make a fuss about it they let the media
continue to paint bank americart as a
tool for fosters as this simply deterred
competitors from entering the space
this strategy worked for a couple of
years but by 1966 it was clear that bank
americard was making bank
initially bank americart was only meant
for california because federal laws
restricted bank of america from directly
expanding to other states but an
up-and-coming competitor called master
charge had figured out a workaround
mastercharge had created an alliance
between a bunch of regional banks to
circumvent federal laws seeing this bank
of america decided to do the same thing
and given their brand power this
strategy was extremely powerful starting
in 1966 bank of america began signing
licensing agreements with banks outside
of the state but they soon came across
another federal hurdle
in 1970 the federal government would
outlaw banks from sending unsolicited
credit cards to americans so bank of
america could no longer just send their
cards to as many people as they could
and hope that people would bite but
really this was a bigger problem for
competitors than bank of america bank of
america had already sent out over 100
million credit cards by the time this
law came around so the law really just
stifled competition in the meantime bank
of america took this opportunity to
focus on international expansion between
1968 and 1977 for example bank of
america partnered with an alliance of
canadian banks to issue a credit card
named chargex
similarly they would bring out carte
blue and friends and they also brought
out options in japan the uk and spain
but as the card spread around the world
bank america started to become a larger
and larger part of bank of america bank
americart was no longer bank of
america's card it was simply a popular
card that was owned by bank of america
in other words bank americart was
becoming an independent business that
was no longer reliant on bank of america
and the bank of america was actually
stifling the reach of bank americart
here's the thing not everyone in the
world is big fans of america especially
during the cold war and the inflation
crisis of the 1970s many international
customers refused to get a card that was
associated with bank of america if the
bank was named chase or wells fargo they
might have had an easier time with
international customers but their name
was literally bank of america now bank
of america isn't actually a central or
national bank like the bank of canada or
the swiss national bank but the name
does create such an image aside from
this association bank americart's
dealings became increasingly messy as
bank of america signed deals with
various banks around the world they
agreed to varying transaction fees
bearing licensing fees and varying terms
and conditions this made the system
extremely unorganized and difficult to
manage so in 1970 de hawk the chairman
of the bank of marquardt committee
proposed the idea of spinning off bank
americart into its own company bank of
america would agree and a new company
called nbi or national bank america dink
was created for domestic relations and
the d-hawk would be made ceo however
bank of america retained a right to
continue issuing bank america arts
outside of the u.s and forming new
partnerships bank of america wasn't
actually that good at this though and it
didn't take long for this to turn into a
massive mess as well by 1972
international partners were starting to
get frustrated with bank of america and
wanted a more streamlined process so
bank of america would seek help from
d-hawk eventually they would work out a
deal and create a new company called
ebenko or international bank card
company for international relations
this new system of ebenko and nbi was
actually pretty effective but by 1976
the companies came to the conclusion
that there was no reason to operate as
separate entities so in 1976 the two
companies merged and created what we now
know as visa
now that all of the background issues
were taken care of visa could focus on
improving the service this included
supporting more currencies offering cash
withdrawals around the clock launching
the debit card and so on and so forth
but by far their biggest challenge was
addressing credit card fraud
unfortunately this couldn't really be
addressed until technology advanced much
more but visa introduced fraud
protection services as soon as they
could
in 1993 for instance visa started
utilizing neural network technology to
better identify fraudulent payments but
their biggest step against fraud didn't
come till 2004 when they introduced
advanced authorization
advanced authorization leverages machine
learning and risk management tools to
assign a risk core to every visa
transaction in real time
for example if you go grocery shopping
every friday and one week you go on
wednesday that payment would be assigned
a higher risk score similarly if you
live in austin but go on vacation to new
york and make a purchase there that
transaction would have a much higher
risk score while this system is quite
effective and has allowed for more
consumer friendly fraud policies critics
have argued that the system is intrusive
in order to identify these anomalies
visa needed to know your purchasing
habits and travel life pretty well
despite these concerns though visa's
growth has never slowed down as consumer
spending just keeps going up year after
year in 1997 visa reached 1 trillion in
annual payment volume within just 10
years though this over quadrupled to 4.4
trillion dollars in 2008 visa would go
public and since then the stock has run
over 1100
making them the 13th largest company in
the world with a valuation of 438
billion dollars and when you control
their credit card market and have 500
margins that's really not that
surprising do you guys have a visa
powered credit card comment that down
below
also drop a like if you're a master at
milking credit card rewards and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest futurity ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]
you